(phone alert)
Yeah, I'd love a noon facial
with David.
Okay, is Lisa P. available?
Manicure, pedicure?
No, it has to be Lisa P.
I'll take any appointment
available.
Oh, yeah, Lisa M. is fine.
No, I will not see Philippe.
Phillippe hurt me once and I
think I complained about that.
Kegels?
Hmm...
(speaking Korean)
Disgusting.
What are you guys
talking about?
Yeah, hi.
I can't come in today.
Well, then I quit.
Do you wax?
Okay... how's the ass (bleep)
reshaping?
Should I get a
diamond or a heart?
A four-leaf clover.
I need all the luck I can get.
(bleeps)
Oh, hi! I thought
you were coming later.
Do you want to have sex with me?
I do.
Ugh...
Oh.
Come on, bitch.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Oh, my God, so you get
off holidays?
(doorbell)